and then in the next scene you see this
model home up for destruction it's quite
an interesting scene symbolically you
see in the middle of this house here
there's a stained glass window that has
a Mandela on it we'll see it more
clearly in a minute and Mandela is a
sacred symbol of the self that's that's
the Union interpretation it's a symbol
it's very difficult to describe but it's
it's a symbol music is a Mandela except
it's played out across time so you could
say that that thing is the same as music
but it's kind of like a slice of music
it's it's it's the same idea you know
sometimes mmm you see those slow motion
or sped up motion videos of a flower
unfolding that's the same it's the same
idea you can imagine that being set to
music and somehow that would make sense
and the Mandela is like a symbol of the
unfolding of being and/or the source of
meaning or something like that and it's
also a symbol of the self from the Union
perspective and so there you see it more
clearly the kids are starting to burn
this place and to trash it and they're
dragging a grand piano down the down the
stairs the destruction of high culture
about which they're nothing but cynical
because they don't believe that hard
work and sacrifice can can produce
something of any value and they want to
bring it down and destroy it and that's
partly because you can see this in the
story of Cain and Abel table is
hard-working and everyone likes him and
he makes the proper sacrifices and so
his life goes really well and that's
part of the reason that Cain hates him
and he's jealous and resentful but worse
than that if you're around someone if
you're not doing very well especially if
that's your own fault if you're not
doing very well and you're around
someone who's doing very well it's very
painful because the mere fact of their
being judges you and so it's very easy
to want to destroy that to destroy that
ideal so that you don't have to live
with the terrible consequences of seeing
it embodied in front of you and so part
of the reason that people want to tear
things down is so that they don't have
anything to contrast themselves against
and to feel bad and that's exactly
what's happening here the kids are
destroying all of this
culture roughly speaking because it
judges them the fact that it exists
judges them and I've often thought this
about Michelangelo's Statue of David
which is this heroics so David was a
shepherd obviously and it doesn't sound
like much but back in those times being
a shepherd was a big deal because their
reliance and you had a slingshot and so
like you got to defend your sheep from
lions with a slingshot
so you weren't exactly this like 19th
century English guy dressed in a you
know frilly blue suit you were tough as
a bloody well someone who would go after
a lion with a slingshot
it's no joke anyways the statue is very
heroic and you know you look at that you
think well that's the possibility of of
humankind but by the same token it's
also what you're not and so as well as
being an ideal it's a judge and every
ideal is a judge so yes yep so you're
becoming bitter as a result of not being
able to achieve success he's yeah but
yeah in the example of Cain and Abel
yeah like one was a shepherd yeah I was
a farmer I'm the one who no no one is
yes that's right whatever yes oh the
shepherd was the one who was favorite
yes that's right it was not a result of
the hard work good question stories well
that's a good question those stories are
very very complicated and the story is
very ambivalent about whether Cain is
not rewarded because he makes bad
sacrifices or because God's just in a
bad mood and that I like that if you
read the story I've read multiple
translations of the story and when when
Cain comes to God to complain God
basically tells them look buddy before
you go about criticizing the structure
of reality you should look to your own
inadequacies he says sin crouches out
your door like a predatory sexually
aroused animal and you invited it in to
have its way with you
something has emerged as a consequence
so be bothered me about my creation
before you look to yourself so there's a
very strong hint that the reason that
God has not favoured Cain sacrifices is
because they weren't a particularly good
quality so but that but it is ambivalent
in the story and there is the Shepherd
versus farmer motif as well and of
course that motif runs through the whole
entire corpus of stories to some degree
especially the Shepherd motif so it's
only about a paragraph long that whole
story and it packs all that into that
tiny little amount of space but the the
idea that Cain kills Abel to get rid of
his ideal and also to punish God roughly
speaking it's a brilliant story I mean
these guys who go around shooting up
high schools or shooting up high schools
in particular but you know they're
definitely out for revenge and what
their revenge against or to who is not
exactly clear anyway so these kids are
just tearing down this model home
tearing down Western civilization I
suppose is another way of looking at or
just tearing down civilization period
and Pinocchio is having a pretty good
time he's got his axe and he's looking a
little malevolent there and and happy to
be destroying things which is of course
a pretty simple thing to do so there's
that image that I told you about the
Mandela that's a flower in this image
and and so what happens is that I think
it's lamp-wick throws a brick through it
and so what that means symbolically is
this the self is a symbol of your
potential among very many other things
but by engaging in this sort of
impulsive destructive activity
lamp-wick and Pinocchio are making it
impossible for them to further their
development and they're doing that to
some degree consciously you know they
basically say to hell with it and toss a
brick through this highest ideal the
thing through which light shines so also
that harkens back to the to the star as
well so